on the island of evia by ancient olympia
people are flare
wildfires have closed in on these shores
and residents and tourists are being
crowded onto ferries and fishing boats
leaving behind the burning island
but it is in the suburbs of athens where
fires are burning most intensely
[Music]
[Applause]
here a woman shouts for help bring water
she says the houses
temperatures here have been over 40
degrees and there are now more than 150
wildfires across the country
two people are known to have died
i want to reassure all those affected by
the fires that they are my first
priority all the burned land will be
reforested and we will change the way
that we carry out flood protection and
fire prevention works
[Applause]
21 british firefighters have been sent
to greece to help
but unpredictable winds are making the
flames difficult to control
houses factories livelihoods are gone
animals
left behind
[Music]
greece like so much of europe is
grappling with extreme weather
and as this part of the mediterranean
burns and thousands are forced to flee
their homes
more difficult nights will come ali
fortescue sky news